there are only seven years left to meet
the UN Development Goal of eradicating
hunger by 2030. so time is short and the
stakes are high for parliamentarians
from 80 countries who attended the
second parliamentary Summit on fighting
hunger and malnutrition in Valparaiso
Chile
opening the summit Chile's president
described hunger as a Calamity that
knows no borders
even if there was only one person going
hungry that would be scandalous but its
850 million people and so this Summit
with the support of the FAO is
tremendously important
do you earn food and agriculture
organization says that parliamentarians
have a key role in passing budgets
enacting laws and holding governments to
account
so of course parliamentarians in the
role of garnering political will have a
major role to play now if the
governments have the political will and
they allocate enough budget instead of
dedicating budget for example
conflicts to Wars to buy arms if they
dedicate a little bit of that to food
security
we're solving the problem of hunger
every continent suffers from hunger and
malnutrition but the reasons vary from
poverty drought floods lack of
infrastructure and technical support for
Farmers the Young Generation the product
age should go into Agriculture and we
should come up with some
incentives for the young Farmers every
country in Africa 10 percent of his
annual budget to be appropriated it has
to be it has to go towards agriculture
armed conflicts such as the war in
Ukraine also impact hunger directly or
indirectly but can it be reversed can we
say that we achieve I don't know but the
point is where we are where we go
parliamentary impact
practitioners
sign Raider commitment towards larger
budgets to guarantee food security for
greater coordination and cooperation
amongst the countries and their
parliaments and especially a focus on
sustainable Food Systems you see in
human Al Jazeera Valparaiso